we're doing it how come my headphones
are weird how come my right ear is good
but not my left ear but it's some down
here isn't a jiggle jiggle the penis
speaking of jiggling penis during roses
here ladies and gentlemen what a
terrible introduction my preferred
introduction yeah well that's what I got
it from your publicist yeah yeah well it
puts the right thought and everyone's
head right away right away people know
that you're funny and that you jiggle
your penis now welcome to Los Angeles
thank you how long have you been here
four years you have yeah three years
yeah but but but didn't you recently
move here like officially or you were
back in Canada or what no I am I was in
Canada yeah Willie man yes but I just
happened to be there oh okay so that was
a random thing and I'm sure we even
spoke about that but you know how when
you meet someone in a location you're
like tied to that location right see the
weird my brain out of that locate my
brain and like wait you can't live in
California because I met you at a sports
bar in Toronto yeah but you're still on
a lot of you still on a couple different
shows in Canada right yeah I'm on a
sitcom in Canada at mr. d yeah and yeah
I go up there to work yeah that's right
yeah yeah and why'd you take your
headphones off but what I realized is I
can hear you because we're only three
feet away from each other
I just I'm always a headphone guy but oh
really people some people aren't some
people aren't aren't a headphone thing
okay no like additional music or sound
cues nothing no there's not there's not
that I unless Aaron you've got something
up your sleeve that would be very fun if
of Aaron play a slide whistle or
something today's tricks daybreak yeah
yeah he's working out stuff all week
ah so let's go through a listeners worst
birthday yes Charlie so for those of you
that are new to the podcast you can
always call and leave out your worst
birthday at nine oh nine five two worst
nine oh nine five two worst or you can
even outnumber I know the night I yeah I
got a number you get it spelled out
though like that yeah that's great yeah
I know I know what's that area code what
is it I think it's like Arkansas I mean
it was just a random number I wanted I
wanted a Michigan number right where I'm
from but I couldn't get it you guys you
can always email me your worst birthday
Michael and Michael Kosta calm so I want
go through this one I think it's pretty
interesting and I'm curious to hear what
you have to say about it down right so
let me just paraphrase this for you this
comes from Albert I'm not going to say
his last name I don't think I have to
this was three or four years ago my
brother was going to take you to dinner
at Fogo de Chao a you know that place
pho go to Albert likes to Bray that's
exactly I've never I've never known
anyone to go to that place did you know
that I've ever heard of it now it's like
the Argentinian Oh like the me that's
like yeah Brazilian it's Brazilian ah
whatever
here we go Aaron see that's the sound
cue you would have missed it I spent my
birthday evening waiting for my brother
to show up and he never did okay ouch I
saw him at my mother's house not long
after that he refused to acknowledge it
or even apologize
I was then invited to his wedding which
I did not attend an email saying I would
not I would not be making him during my
sister's last visit she had mentioned
that my brother was sorry and we should
go over there and speak with him I went
with my sister we smoked weed he never
apologized but he did give me a couple
of buds of pot to take home okay my
birthday was on the 14th of this month
and on this day he left me a voicemail
wishing a happy birthday in a statement
saying he owed me a dinner or two I'm
still waiting for that technically I've
forgotten him but I'm still feeling way
too bitter about sitting down at the
restaurant that he never showed up at
I've always wanted to go I'm not looking
for any interaction with my brother do
you think I should send him a copy of
this email let's not forget he never
officially apologised derogate what's
going on your brain here Darren Albert
thinks his birthday is way too important
yeah okay thank us Albert that's not the
appropriate response to somebody missing
a birthday dinner skip their wedding
yeah that wasn't that's a big that's a
big comeback thank you no big jumping
yeah that's like when a Drake drop
back-to-back yes it was like okay yeah
yeah right your brother's been
obliterated like Meek Mill um he did
obliterate Meek Mill so you
this is an Albert and his brother is a
is a Drakon non Meek Mill
I do think you know yeah Albert it's
just too crazy my brother didn't show up
- okay okay you're right you're right I
agree with you because I think not
showing up to your mother's wedding is
huge offense
that being said mm-hmm why the [ __ ] did
his brother not pick him up and take him
to this restaurant or where was he we're
waiting to show up you oh it doesn't
want to mention it yeah and that's yeah
I mean that's a big one
it is definitely rude yeah from
everything we know about Albert was just
absolutely nothing other than is almost
nothing but I suspect Albert might be a
handful yeah yeah we know about Albert
yeah
takes his birthday's really seriously
smokes a lot of weed does likely and
accepts apologies in weed form yeah well
yeah that was well and what's funny
about that is the email he may have sent
that to me hi and you're welcome to do
that listeners Oh where's Judy please oh
he that the signature of his email was
all these weed things I'm like you know
this is maybe why you don't broadcast
your email address to the whole world
but I do think my brother's skipping a
brother's birthday it's pretty bad
I mean I'm selling Jones I do yeah well
what do you have I have a brother and on
his birthday I text him happy birthday
yeah and then on my birthday he takes me
happy birthday that we're adults yeah
but but that's but you don't make plans
and then don't even explain or show up
that's that's the worst part
okay I unders you know and also maybe
Albert's brother smokes even more weed
than Alberta I've got a feeling that
maybe some weed involved too few dope
but then you would think if you're hot
you'd want to go to that Brazilian steak
place you would think yeah yeah lots of
food there um what is your is your
brother older or younger older okay and
what is your family's tradition with
birthdays growing up what was it well
this is a weird podcast for me to be on
because my family's tradition is yeah
forget entirely really yeah 100%
Albert yeah Albert yeah we're Alberta
each other all the time yeah so with
what is your birthday my birthday is
March 18th okay cool and
my brother now were raised by my dad
okay and for my whole life my parents
got divorced not six months old okay
and do you think it was your birth that
maybe I do think so yeah it doesn't
really feel like it was my fault that's
why I do stand-up comic and my dad we
just forget all the time really yeah we
like my birthday like when I was eight
uh my dad just forgot my birth didn't
mention it nothing really came up but I
want to bring it out yeah I just let her
ride I let her ride then like a week
later he was like hey I got you a cat
just in general yeah what were your
birthday like essentially for my birth
but obviously they give you a cat we
just got that house of cat yeah you got
the house and he's just like all right
did he and I don't want to you know was
he a good dad oh yeah he was a good dad
yeah it's just not caught up on like it
was just my birthday you know yeah that
long ago three months ago and so two
months ago a month after my birthday I
had dinner with my dad yeah and he gave
me two hundred dollars and said buy
yourself a birthday card I like that
yeah well I was talking to Sabrina
Jalees who was on last week her mom
emails her and says I put a hundred
bucks in your account like it's like
where I come from it is a [ __ ] card
that everyone you sent you sign a little
message like a message I thought that's
what everybody did until I learned from
other families that have bad parents
apparently that uh yeah sometimes you
just direct deposit some money and go
that's for your birthday remember when
you were a little kid in the card was
the worst part yeah something about if
you got for sure you know I get it how
old people would always open the card
neck wide open in the cart open the kid
that is very it's a great point the
cards make me cry now right a card is
you guys thought of Oh a beautiful
relationship I can always rely on like
oh and a bottle of cologne who cares who
cares yeah my parents we joke with my
parents because if you when they start
reading the card you have about three
seconds before they start crying it's
just like a and they've gotten older and
way worse I mean it's like crying all
the time now what kinds of stuff are
being written in these Kaido know that
we were just a very I guess close family
and when and we when we never really
said I love you but I felt you felt it
right so then I think when you when
when my mom would read it or my dad they
would I don't know they're just also
just old people cry a lot do you notice
that I think it's because their friends
are dying how you doing mom and dad
you see yeah so do you remember like
your eighth birthday waking up and being
excited and then and then no one else
knew or gave a [ __ ] like is that a
strong memory um well yeah but it's most
of my birthday's were like that okay it
was never it was never it's just like my
dad comes home with a plastic bag from
the pharmacy I picked up some stuff like
you were just job shopping it yet milk
isn't a birthday gift yeah totally yeah
or ever I remember once my dad when the
movie Dick Tracy came out or no no no
that no that wasn't my birthday
it was the transformer the one where he
they have like the cassette tape in the
chest
yeah which guy that was he was there and
we'll find that out for at some point
yeah it was awkward
he doesn't have to google it he doesn't
even have the [ __ ] good also had it
yeah well I probably had it too but I've
moved on as he knows it in his brain he
knows that that was chocolate
I heard my dad bought it for me and then
forgot to give it to me oh man I didn't
gave it to me the following year yeah
but I like the idea that he clearly he's
not find it exactly twelve months later
yeah he obviously like you know found it
like you know two months after yeah well
it's too late now
how do I I'll just wait ten months was
he was he like did he drank your dad was
it no no I just just would forget stuff
like it was a busy guy he ran his own
company uh and and so what was the
company who is in industry doesn't even
exist anymore glass typesetting what the
[ __ ] is typeset typesetting used to be
before the advent of computers what's a
computer you would get a like a
typewritten manuscript right and then
there's a stage between that and the
printed book which is you have to
arrange where they'll go on the page yes
which when I was a really little kid it
was still like Gutenberg style it's
called hot type we are taking individual
letters in Reverse and putting them I
mean essentially the typewriter right
it's like the except you would form a
plate and that would like stamp it or
some exactly you'd form plates and that
would stamp it and that way you don't
typewriter you know the letter B far
apart yeah the can swing and so you know
if you had graphics yet to decide you
know what affix go or where the page
numbers tell and stuff like that it this
industry has completely got to be
completely gone it was gone like in the
80s what became cheap enough once
computers became Chiado I remember my
dad had computers that were like about
the size of this dad and then a screen
left this big right just green right
text right but it was massive all we had
you know half of the power of your
iPhone I mean it's it's funny to think
now if I want the photo to be arranged
differently you click it and just drag
it we're back in the day there was a
person moving that photograph yeah
there's a person with like an exacto
knife slicing it out to create a
photographic slate
oh we take itself for granted yeah
there's a shocking that the whole thing
is gone yeah well my father ran a travel
agency which is Pratt I mean right now
gone yeah now they now they focus on
tours which are still exist thankfully
but that's like think about that I mean
used to call travel agent and book a
flight I remember I used to run a
software company and so there's a
software company but we still had a
travel agent yeah because I was in the
2000 okay
where it still wasn't was it he have
full trust yeah the internet yet yeah it
was a crazy thing to be in control of
booking your own flight right were you
doing comedy when you were running when
you were in software company no I
started after that company didn't work
after that didn't work and said to
yourself I think I could do this or what
yeah well I had a friend of mine who had
a TV show nice and I thought I started
casting about for something to do and I
thought well maybe I'll get one of those
right because I didn't know that was
hard
yeah exactly right off so hard very hard
yeah turns out other people are also
trying that's like yeah I didn't know
that's like hey I was watching Wimbledon
I decided hey I should just go play
Wimbledon
yeah a little harder than that yeah do
the listeners know your your tennis
history I don't know I don't know if
they know anything about me
you're one once one of the what top
twenty top thirty hyannis players in
America I love that you are saying those
numbers high my career high was 864 in
the world in the world in singles so
and I made $11,000 over four years so as
a professional tennis vessel which is
the idea that you were good enough to
get paid to be correct tens I mean it's
astounding I realize you want to be
self-deprecating by say goes a lot of
thousand but thank you for saying that
what's most astounding to me is that
whenever I tell a group of people my
ranking what's why but that was my high
they always laugh like that and I'm
always like [ __ ] you yeah it was that I
mean I'm not trying to be a dick and I'm
not a world champion but I'm like that's
really [ __ ] good but they it's just
people just hear the numbers and it's
like it essentially it's like I played
baseball for the Marlins and I got
traded around me it's like you're still
pretty good [ __ ] baseball player you
still in the game yeah yeah the idea
like people just aren't counted because
I think only like your 800 and yeah
actually fifth you know they think oh
how many people are trying yeah exactly
tens of thousands but yeah they ranked
at least 10,000 there's I like Molina
Marlins I'm just I'm really triple a
double a triple A's probably where I
meant I see Aaron was a little smirk on
his face but oh there's a lot more
baseball players than there are ranked
tennis players I would think so you know
do that what is the 30 guys on a
baseball team
30 teams there's 900 guys yeah so yeah
that's the number right there anyway
you're on the lazy legs yeah may may not
be good
what might a Marlins what is your
besides comedy what is your you know
what what are you passionate about that
isn't stand-up comedy like math and
facts for real those two fish yeah a
little bit haughty with like how do you
casually like math I mean I'm serious
how does one like like you just are
really good at adding up your golf card
I used to have a job after my software
job I had a job at Heinz ketchup and
okay marketing but the jobs actually you
run the brand so yeah a product and then
you're in charge of everything from like
the inventory and the packaging to the
advertising and God ever and so a lot of
it was just math you just go with sheets
of numbers to every meeting and try and
forecast demand like data on one who's
buying it
yeah you know like a the scanner at the
supermarket uh the reason that exists is
to sell the data back to everyone luck
who makes tide and paste occasionally
what's because they can see who's
buying it in which store we ran a coupon
increase right right you know who we
lose a shelf space to they measure inch
by inch all the shelf
I know shelf space is like [ __ ] war
for these people it's a huge war and it
cost so much money to get a product on a
shelf it's hundreds of thousands of
dollars to buy the space so the Heinz
will approach whoever owns a chain of
grocery stores and actually pay them to
be at the eye level
yourself they go high round that should
be illegal shouldn't it it seems like it
should yes everything a capitalism
should be illegal yeah yeah they go
we're going to introduce Tabasco ketchup
yeah one size it's a you know 350
milliliter bottle yeah and we'd like to
listen Roscoe's yeah why don't you just
give us six hundred grand no [ __ ]
and they go okay and then they put it
right there put it right there and then
if it doesn't sell Ralph just kicks it
out yeah thanks for your 600 grand and
the guys that's doubt the weird hot
sauce that's down below that guy's like
dust on it yeah yeah those people just
probably more independent they can't
afford to buy the space yeah they still
pay for that space but they only have
like 20 grand like high like caves hot
sauce yeah he's only in one store yeah
because you can only buy joy then he's
saving up another 20 grand get to the
second story
second story so in a lot of ways comedy
I mean this must have helped you I mean
are you are you good are you good at
promoting your comedy I'm pretty good at
that they're pretty decent at a-- yeah
yeah like I like in Canada I promote my
own tours and and you're running your
own expenses and I'll run my own
expenses yeah you know I'd like book the
theatres and write like get the
Ticketmaster contract yeah book the
Google Ads manage the here that American
comedians this is what [ __ ] people in
other countries and he's running his own
[ __ ] tour
I always thought fear tours of these so
cool and then I was talking to Daniel
Tosh and he's like no we pay for
everything it's so like this he's like
he's the first time you do one he's like
yeah you order the the meat tray for the
deli from the deli then you realize oh
that's $200 of my money so now he's like
we have one bottled water in the green
room that's yes because we're paying for
it yeah I remember on my first tour
you go out to the lobby afterwards they
say hi to people okay you want like a
table you can put your drink on her
since okay sure yeah I get the feel
afterwards of 75 blood or the table for
them to put the table outside what that
would [ __ ] drive me crazy oh yeah
ever you pay for everything yeah yeah
yeah well your background probably helps
you with that yeah I think it makes it
seem like a manageable possibility yeah
where is it maybe if I didn't have that
background I just got weird he start
yeah I mean that's kind of where I'm at
yeah where to start yeah so um we got
off topic not not that it matters but I
want to get back to your birthday so
right tell me tell me what else is there
another one that's besides your eighth
birthday that was that was bad that you
can remember or just they just weren't
existed it didn't exist they mostly
didn't exist and also here's my theory
on birthdays yeah is a this entire
podcast is basically about expectation
correct and people's expectations are
high and then that's why the
disappointment is owed 93 something what
guests have finally figured out what
this [ __ ] podcast is exactly right
well the ROM is always you know Albert
sitting there and he goes well this is
going to be great me my brother going to
reconnect it's gonna be a lot of fun I
feel like I'm important to my brother
yeah and then he doesn't show up and
Albert's like well Jesus Christ yeah I
believed in him yeah but if Albert was
just like just sitting at home and goes
well somebody picks me up fine nobody
does he'd be happy today but you can't
go through life with shitty expectations
for everything you can't but you can go
in and sell whatever you expect ok
appropriate so what would the
appropriate expectation from Albert be
and that's the twist interpret by the
way Albert thanks for the email we were
really talking about this yeah yeah
we've got in people Albert yeah here's
my thing if you're an adult yeah shut up
about your birthday for this for
children here in a head doll or women it
seems like you love their birthdays more
than that I think with this general I
think there's a I think that is true and
there's a weird there's a three-stage
process to birthday interest when your
agents very young a birthday is
something that's thrown for you yeah
it's a celebration you're excited about
it yeah and then as you get into your
20s people stop caring you like your
family stops caring about your birthday
probably when you're like 18 yeah for
most people yeah I think like it just
becomes less of a thing
you know they put $100 in Sabrina's
account or whatever yeah they start
writing your cards instead of buying you
things you have on scarf and then and
then in your 20s your birthday is
something that you're promoting right a
way to hang out with your friends right
it's my people over for my birthday hey
I'm sorry we haven't talked all year
right you know but I'd like you to come
to my have text message from people like
hey I'm doing a birthday thing tonight
the last text message I have from them
was a year ago at their birthday it's a
slightly [ __ ] you right and we're not
really friends you just need me to show
up to your thing to make them feel
better about how many friends they had
yeah and then they look cool in front of
their friends you know they're like
three people they ever hang out with go
like will you so many people Wow they're
like just digging you like the dredges
of Facebook it's true yeah I went to
public school with this guy yeah and
this a vanity it so it becomes like this
thing you're promoting for a few years
yeah sort of probably into your late 20s
and then it goes through a lull
yeah and then hopefully at some point
you find someone in your life who then
wants to celebrate you again yeah
becomes like childhood where it's like
surprise party yeah and that sort of
thing but there's but I do think once
you're an adult just I'm kind of with
you yeah your expectations should be
zero it your expectations should be zero
I don't I don't like that I don't like
zero I think your expectations should be
like you don't want to set them too hot
because look essentially this podcast
more or less is people who have set the
bar too high and then get drastically
disappointed it's like New Year's Eve
it's almost usually the right party of
the year totally because you go [ __ ]
you got you did your hair and you got
all [ __ ] but I like the idea of
birthdays about how as you get older it
becomes even a bigger celebration
because it's like holy [ __ ] this guy's
[ __ ] 88 right like you really you
really have to hear right we really have
to party I was I was as a jacked about
this weekend there was a guy 88 in the
in the audience people were going up to
him shaking his hand saying hey so cool
you're here it's just a minke as you as
you get so close to death people are
really celebrating right cuz it feels
like a magic trick yeah
here are you still doing it yeah you're
right it becomes yeah and I have to
imagine that's dispiriting if you're a
little bit right because then you really
feel like you're realizing the tug of
death yeah could you laughs why is
everyone freaking out I can pass your
expiration date buddy yeah I want to
live to be 140 why are they celebrating
this ah how long is this not going to be
good what do you do for your brother's
birthday you said you text what do you
do for your dad's birthday
nothing nothing nothing yeah I'll call
them but I know your dad's birthday yeah
you do actually my dad's birthday is on
Saturday hey happy it's also easy to
remember everyone in my family's
birthday my mother's birthday is a week
before my brother's which is a week
before my dad's okay and what's what
month is that I
April 9th May 2nd 13 so they're all they
yeah okay got it that's weird my also
Emily's in September which is always
kind of funny Oh read the whole thing
three out of four kids are in September
it makes it easier to remember yeah
you're right I think there's a for a
long time I couldn't remember which one
was my dad's birthday and which one was
my brothers you have to remind myself I
may have text my sister last week and I
said I know my mom and dad's birthday is
coming up but I need help you need to
have that you need to have someone in
the family that knows the dates you need
to have someone yeah yeah what did you
do March 18th three weeks ago
now as an adult you still don't do
anything no one day though no one takes
you out to dinner
do you do a comedy show do you treat it
as just a normal day of work I just
treat it as a normal day I remember
where I was where was I remember where I
was yeah I don't know I don't do
anything I will tell you there's one
weird thing about my birthday because
it's March 18 yeah it's the day after
st. Patrick's Day oh yeah so there's
always sort of a built-in party that's
nice
where if I want to it's possible to go
get drinks yeah but I used to in college
my college roommate his birthday was st.
Patrick's Day God and so we would always
have a party that weekend and but like
college style like all our place garbage
so we're like yet everybody come and
kick the windows out let's do this why
would you ever own a house and rent to a
college kid I can tomato my have to be
let me just think back I was a good kid
right our place
is a [ __ ] disaster yeah oh yeah I was
a good kid it was a mess I remember one
particular party we had in college yeah
and we had like kind of eleven people
come for the weekend right in the three
bedroom I can discuss like there's
people sleeping in the hallway it's
gross and I remember my brother was
there and so my brother's name is
Darrell Oh
Darrell and Darren are you guys close
yeah it was my close yeah what college
is this this is at Concordia University
in Montreal in Montreal and and there's
these buddies of ours who are twins in
the name [ __ ] omelette oh [ __ ] the
most why is this not a TV show yeah we
were cursed early they're like
[ __ ] ammad and they sort of we
sort of matched up like because my
brother's like a big beefy like iron
worker tough guy huh and so all mid was
like this big beefy like rugby playing
tough guy and then Muhammad SAW was like
sin kind of proper but they were also
both their parents are diplomats they
carry themselves right right like well
it's worth this party and they'd um we
drink like a million drinks and they
were going to go and come back when I
was drinking montreal college is it just
[ __ ] [ __ ] beers that like it's not
Canadian it was [ __ ] beer and then at
the time there was this crazy French
idea where they started putting like
lemon-lime flavor and beer for God's
sake it was called a boomerang boomerang
boomerang I know boomerang really I
think I I was just in Montreal is it
possible that I that it still exists Oh
entirely possible yeah I might be but I
think it's like a french-canadian thing
that's such a terrible idea it was so
quick everything you drink it yeah yeah
we drag it and also you know you don't
have a beer as an acquired taste
and before you fully acquire this
actually what might a little lemon-lime
flavor well why does every vodka company
make like you know strawberry vodka it's
nothing because if adults don't want
that it's to get kids in on it yeah yeah
yeah only my my buddy stayed at my place
you know Nathan Macintosh in New York I
don't know if I know Nathan mad complain
it's a really funny guy and he was out
here to do Conan and then and then
stayed for a while so they put him in
the hotel for two days but then he
stayed at my place and
and I wasn't here but he left me as a
thank you a bottle of pineapple Ciroc oh
yeah and I was like come on buddy good
no no no I thought it was a joke it's a
funny joke yeah that's what I was like I
just but he doesn't really drink it so
I'm sure he just thought it was a nice
thing and I was like I'm never gonna
drink this I went out like oh let me
just try it turns out delicious oh
really so really that's so funny I was
like I'm a little bit of a 18 year old
woman right now
drink that on the rocks yeah just drank
it on the rock yes yeah it was delicious
so what about this party with Mohammed
Ilana this is uh this is exactly why you
shouldn't rent to students they're kind
of leaving and with this girlfriend
everything I mean my brother's for
saying goodbye to though but I'm trying
to be nice but we've been out drinking
forever and you know I'm a teacher so
I'm just throwing up over the stairs
then you know they're on my right I just
turn to the left throwing you're
throwing hey guys who so nice you to
come I'm so glad you could be here
trying to match their sort of diplomat
here though just one legged like [ __ ]
disgusting so embarrassed thanks for
coming to my birthday party guys we are
our college apartment people would pull
the fire alarm all the time as like a
fun joke right so which by the way I
believe is a federal crime and then so
then another federal crime which we did
was we disconnected it you know you got
a [ __ ] ladder and you just don't want
it it's easy you just take the [ __ ]
thing so then the next morning we wake
up like pounding on the door yeah and
it's the [ __ ] fire department though
because they can tell they're like is
there a fire like like you know why is
this thing disconnected because you do
not yeah we got fined and the end of
tenant got fine but it was just like the
[ __ ] that we would do III never
understand why you would rent right that
was almost on the front page at the
newspaper probably like that's a tragedy
just like all the doors open in instead
of a lead or they disconnected the fire
alarms all these stupid fire cookies um
what was what was a great birthday
you've had if you can if you can
remember one a great birthday yeah what
about in school as a kid it's March 18th
he didn't do anything this year you know
what what comes to mind the saddest
answer yeah over go to McDonald's for
your birthday or yeah the best birthday
you can have I like how dare it is
they set the bar low kind of you know
that you know the quote do you know the
quote by mouse a tongue those what is
the quote I almost sounded smart for a
second though we can edit this part out
yeah I want edit this part no we'll keep
this in ah those with no expectations
cannot be disappointed it's something
along those lines right maybe you're
fearing disappointment I think I was
from a young age condition yeah to be
disappointed yeah and then realize that
I should just have no expectations ever
fun and you can't get disappointed yeah
was it a happy household you and your
bro and your dad oh yeah it was great
yeah it was mom in your life at all yeah
we would see my mom on weekends okay guy
yeah okay it's so it was perfectly fine
yeah you know having able is just you
know sometimes these details fall
through the cracks well I also think you
know being able to celebrate a birthday
we had four kids in our house and my
parents did they did a lot for birthdays
but that takes time money effort and you
know depending on what some years were
better than others so yeah it's just
like maybe that wasn't the focus maybe
the focus was raising two [ __ ] kids
and that's right yeah my dad was really
trying to keep his head above water yeah
like I don't know just keep these kids
alive and if I by [ __ ] sound
shockwave and I forget about it right
you know no big deal he's like who cares
yeah he'll Council next year yeah it
does I love that idea of just like a
gifts a gift it doesn't matter
so what McDonald's birthday was that I
remember when I was a little Kea until I
was in grade 3 or third grade yes as we
say here yeah mistakes we live do that
in my neighborhood it was it was all
kids in my neighborhood and so we would
all grow up where I grew up in a town
called Ottawa which is maybe an hour
outside Toronto it's like a blue collar
it's sort of like a Flint Michigan
sure so yes around a car plan you told
me about this place did I really what we
talked about it because I asked you more
about and you said to Flint Michigan so
that's a good reference oh they probably
have palpable drinking water and off
yeah they have very good water which is
nice yeah nice what about it think you
know Flint still doesn't have [ __ ]
drinking water isn't it crazy we can't
fix anything
they don't have drinking water like it
just infuriates me and they're they're
still forcing people to pay penalties
for not
paying the water bill is that where I
owe my guy didn't know that it's like
it's coming out like it's it's sludge
and they're like well if you're not
going to pay we're taking you the car
yeah it's oh that's a good story that
probably people made it up to Canada the
people up there were like this is what
it's like in the States
yeah people in Canada I was always like
when you went to high school or they're
just like bullets whizzing by your face
all the time and I'm like what are you
guys what newspapers are you guys
reading but you know it's very here's
how I here's how I make sense of
everything in America yeah I imagine
America is a third world country that's
a very rich ruling class there we go and
because things don't make sense like I
don't know drinking water I know like
well that's a like a you know what
people from New York I always brag about
the ranking oh my god that is a
third-world boats right to be like we
have the greatest drinking what they
drag so much about their [ __ ] water
but water yeah like that's something you
USA if you live in the Congo in my
village we have good drinking water look
at some funny bit dude yeah this is why
are we bragging about that if you really
shouldn't be like everyone in New York
thinks it's a special honor come on yeah
you're real our country is yeah well
Canada you guys have you quality of life
is very odd that is like bragging about
like look you know in my house and we
got a roof yeah you know we got the best
roof in the world we got a great roof
and we're gonna get the fourth wall soon
right now it's just a cardboard
corrugated cardboard the United States
is the best in the world at killing
people and entertaining people doing
great about those two things yeah we
[ __ ] crushed I didn't want to be all
pessimistic I United States um darren
rowse happy birthday that mcdonald's
birthday would she gets a happy meal in
the toy yeah you get though like the
cheeseburger meal we had a little action
he's a growling right now thinking about
it a good way to go through life may be
worse they think do they all do a
birthday thing I think it's only for
like a like parents who hate their kids
yeah
you think I'm game just so their friends
go with some loser yeah what's wrong we
do get burger kick your parents in have
three more dollars that's 65 more senses
where can people find out all of your
information
I on the image no that's a good play
Twitter I'm at Darren
there we go I'm at Darren Rosen all the
stuff and how do you how do you counter
the Jason Sudeikis look because you must
have walked into many a casting rooms
and you know how do you fight that well
when I first got here yeah everyone said
it yeah and I was like well I got a I
got to change up my look yeah I was like
this is probably getting in the way yeah
so I cut my hair and I shaved my beard
yeah and it turns out that wasn't the
brow was probably us they were looking
for talent aside like I do like to think
unlike maybe acting comedy I think I
hope I hope if they're just funny that
should be that that should eventually
work obviously did your success fee I
have a career but I'm just saying like
the fact that you maybe look like
something shouldn't [ __ ] matter if
you're funny yeah I think it's a gun in
my head about okay you come here yeah I
think like well everything's gonna
change tomorrow yeah if I just get in 10
years yeah you may see about all these
but just wax my arms yeah I am see I'm
gonna make it and yeah it turns out yeah
you just have to rely on this one figure
but working on four wooden used to be
five decades yeah and they're just
trying to be funny and then I found
chips fall where they do what when I
moved here a lot of times they would say
I was too tall and then I found
literally at one point I would walked in
the casting room and I was like trying
to like be less tall and I'm like this
is the definite this is like probably
what women have to deal with all the
[ __ ] time right you can't think about
that [ __ ] I'm like literally trying to
be less tall right you can't do that you
can't yeah yeah they're just like I said
posture we really liked him but he was
hunched over the homes like he doesn't
believe in himself
darren rowse thank you for sharing your
non-existent but worse birthdays thank
you and I hope you have a great March
18th next year thanks man I really
appreciate it thanks for being on the
back sure haven't you got great stuff
that's easy